as the pandemic continues mental health
struggles are taking a toll on thousands
of people
here in clark county there is an effort
underway to shine a light on depression
within our younger people
joe moeller has more on an upcoming
event that could help you
and your family a lot of people are
struggling during the pandemic from
stress related to school to worries
about employment now some mental health
professionals are working to help by
hosting a virtual town hall you can do
from home a lot of kids are
and people in general are struggling
right now the struggle with mental
health has become a reality for far
too many during the pandemic and there
are a number of reasons for it there's a
multitude of factors um i'll say
the first one is the isolation that has
caught that has
that pandemic has created in terms of
you know
folks having to you know spend you know
longer periods of periods of time at
home
dr sheldon jacobs is a licensed marriage
and family therapist he says depression
is up and so is suicide within the youth
in clark county
at thursday night's board of trustees
meeting the topic was discussed
regarding a need for
therapists for students i think that
even anything that we get
is not going to even make a dent like i
we're so
short psychologists that we need in an
innovative solution
dr jacobs says many are finding
themselves in situations they are not
familiar with then parents are having to
find ways to help
trying to stay in tune with kids as much
as possible listen to
to your kids that's a big one listen to
them listening to what's going on their
day
tuesday dr jacobs and the national
alliance on mental illness southern
nevada chapter will host a virtual
discussion about mental health in hopes
of helping families
i felt the need to to do something i
[ __ ] need to you know to provide more
awareness
for our parents and as well as our kids
out there
that town hall is set for tuesday at 5
30. you can find a link to the event up
on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting the newsroom joe mohler 8 news
now